being the governorship and has he asked
you to work for him the question is I
don't know if you could all here but it
was as a former Minnesotan why do I
think of Jesse Ventura being the new
governor of Minnesota and has he asked
me to do any work for him
what are they interesting norm Ornstein
who's my chief of staff my campaign
manager and chief of staff in the book
told me something interesting was that
Minnesota you can register to vote when
you vote so a lot of Jesse's a vote was
people who heard that he was doing well
and decided a lot of young people
particularly and who just decided to go
that day and just said hey he might win
I'm gonna go so that's actually sort of
how he won you know I would have voted
for for skip Humphrey but I think that
so well from what I've understood I
understand he's picked a lot of good
people to surround them and and I
understand why he want I watched the
debates on c-span and he's a very
refreshing guy and and I think the I
hope he does a great job and I haven't
been asked to actually I actually was
asked to tape something which I did for
his party to celebrate the people's
celebration of him so yes
so wonderfully funny describing your
outbreak in Minnesota and I wondered if
you'd be doing some more shows okay the
question is I'm just gonna repeat all
the questions so you don't need to get a
mic the question was well with something
to the effect of how brilliant I was on
ferry so I just wanted to make sure you
all heard that I love Prairie Home
Companion and I've done it a couple
times and I tend to do when he could win
when Garrison comes to New York but it's
a brilliant show yeah who's your
opponent in this book for president man
does Larry Flint play a role in your
book questions one who's my opponent in
the book and and and does Larry Flint
play a part in the book my opponent the
book essentially is is because most a
lot of the book is me trying to get a
lot of the elections me trying to get
the Democratic nomination so my opponent
is Vice President Gore who my character
has tremendous disdain for but who I
personally like very much and then in
the general election it's Newt Gingrich
and he only wins Cobb County and pockets
of Idaho
and larry flynt know has the larry flynt
is mentioned just early on on the on the
cover you see I have the Chief Justice
and there's some letters at the
beginning thing which I asked Chief
Justice to pose for it and and then
asked him if I could use a picture of
him if it would be legal and he cites
Larry Flynt the Campari ad with Falwell
but he asked that I not portray him the
same way Flynt portrayed Falwell which
was having incest in an outhouse but
Larry Flynt you know I I'm I'm hoping
the president gets out of this and so
it's a little weird when Larry Flynt is
sort of on your side although he's done
some great things I've done some rehe
for every sex shop now in California
because of Larry Flynt has a will chance
wheelchair access right
Oh Joe yes are you related to the guy on
CNN with the same name as you and is
that the way get a lot of free press
because he's your cousin well you
answered your own question didn't you
Bob for hey the question is am I related
to the guy with the same name as mine
Bob Franken was on CNN yes I'm proud to
say that Bob and I are cousins were kind
of distant distant cousins but I think I
think Bob has been doing it
terrific job covering this whole thing
last a couple years he was a sign that
evident he got the paula jones beat
early on and was not particularly happy
about it and but it's ballooned into
this and and i think he's doing a great
job the question is how long did it take
me to write the book it took about five
months to write the book is that too
short too long whatever somebody tell me
just write yeah well without seeing
anything suable do you have any juicy
tidbits on a Bob Barr or Tom DeLay and
we'd be writing any that you're asking
for dirt for dirt anything Bob barn Tom
DeLay to two very very hard-working men
I you know I I don't have anything good
to say about him and I've been but Tom
DeLay I actually have something good to
say about Tom DeLay I did I covered the
Republican convention for Comedy Central
and I did an interview with him in which
I asked how he would kill the bugs in
the place because he was an exterminator
and he told me Bob Barr who he might I
mean the thing I don't think it's gotten
enough attention is his visit to the
this racist group that has some odd
ideas as he's called it but but in his
denial that he was there and then I I
believe that he has said maybe someone
will correct me on this but he has said
that taking a Fifth Amendment as an
admission of guilt which is a dangerous
thing for a US Attorney to say and and
then yet he took the equivalent of the
Fifth Amendment in his divorce
proceeding so when he was asked about
adultery but again remember this whole
thing isn't about sex yes the question
is about late wine is anybody here seem
Lateline missing light the question is
do I plan to incorporate any of our
political situation into Lateline well
Lateline is a show that we have we've
shot we have 13 shows that we've in a
can and we shot them all between August
and December so we can't be as topical
as say we were at Saturday Night Live
but Saturday night and it's really hard
to do that in the sitcom because the
waste that comes are produced in the
lead time Saturday Night Live which I
did 15 seasons of we would if if there
was a breaking story we often would wait
until Friday night to actually write the
sketch because things are changing so
fast so on late line we do incorporate
what's happening sort of in the
zeitgeist and we talk about the way the
media is operating and I think we in a
lot of good ways talk about things that
resonate with
sampling but you know we sort of
operated on the role that we're going to
hopefully be seen five ten years from
now and syndication and that in ten
years people will know will remember who
Monica Lewinsky is but hopefully in ten
years they won't remember who Bob Barr
is and so you know I'm not gonna do an
episode about Bob Barr at a racist rally
or Bob Barr lying or a Bob Barr
committing adultery during his second
marriage why would I do that because you
know because it wouldn't make you know
people go Bob Buda
who's that there must be a fictional
character to do all that stuff no no
okay question I haven't I you capture
the the atmosphere of Iowa and New
Hampshire about a year before a primary
really well have you spent a lot of time
in either of those places and are you
worried that the people of New Hampshire
will never let you back for calling them
stupid people in the question did I
wouldn't hear this no the question is in
the book I capture very well the Iowa
and New Hampshire the sort of the year
before the the caucus and the primaries
and have I spent time there and will
these people ever let me back candidate
Franken in his Diaries is continually
talks he's a code in his diary to
describe the people of New Hampshire and
Iowa this is not my feelings Kennedy
frança he used calls them SP he was
totally use a coke code by his lawyer SP
is stupid people so he and again this is
the jerk remember the jerk in here I
have spent a lot of time in on the
campaign trail in Iowa New Hampshire I
have nothing but the greatest respect
for not only the people of Iowa New
Hampshire but the people of Vermont
Nebraska
also Maine and Illinois Minnesota and
Canada I'm just you see what I'm doing
anyway so so yeah this is I think people
law and totally understand the humor of
its it's a guy shooting himself in the
foot but the diary said he that he did
the candy Franken keeps during the
election are subpoenaed by the joint
congressional committee to investigate
the president's mood swings and
ultimately lead to his resignation yes I
think of the Republican response to the
State of the Union address especially as
Steve Largent admitting he didn't know
what GOP stood for you know I missed
that the question is did he really not
know what you know what GOP stood for
but now that he found out he was going
to tell everybody what a great party of
grandeur of Rand
Randall party the question is did I see
Steve Largent and who was the Danford on
give I did not I missed that
but it doesn't surprise me they didn't
know a grand old party meant because a
lot of times in if you go to NFL locker
rooms their knowledge of you know
political history is minimal but he was
a great he was a great receiver they
could they had want great hands and ran
a great pattern can't can't argue that
Brian Paul thing yes have you heard from
or did you hear before you wrote Rush
Limbaugh have you heard from Rush
Limbaugh and if so what did he say okay
the question is did I ever hear from
Rush Limbaugh and if so what he's saying
about a month before the big fat idiot
came out I had my editor send him a book
with it with a little note that said
dear Rush Al thinks would help sales if
you mention the book on your shelf
but he didn't he he doesn't talk about
me much although last May when NBC
announced that we were not on the fall
schedule of Lateline but that we were
picked up for 13 shows on that day rush
announced the next day rush announced
that we had been cancelled and this is
in keeping with well he's just not good
with with what I call facts yes ah the
question is did Arianna Huffington lean
on me in any way for an assistant to
write write her humor book
no no Arianna didn't ask me for any
assistance I I asked me for a quote and
I said I think I said that her book was
like Alice in Wonderland if Alice was
Greek beautiful and evil and she said
yes but can't you say that the book is
funny or something when you say Greek
beautiful funny and evil
yes Stuart Smalley I get this asked a
lot I don't know how many saw Stuart
saves his family one thing I've learned
I've learned something about a way the
show business works evidently if you've
lost 15 million dollars for a studio
they don't want to make the sequel and
if that doesn't tell you everything you
need to know about show business I don't
know what does but I hope to bring back
Stuart in less ambitious ways yes the
fact that you're no longer there so
inferior to how it used to be the
question is why is it that you never say
bad things about friends
exactly
with a whole lot of stuff when you were
little
the question is did I get away with a
whole bunch of stuff when I was little
yes and no I mean I was a very
well-behaved kid by and large I was to
some extent depending on on the teacher
and their point of view either a delight
or a nuisance and in class so I would
sometimes be punished by my teachers my
parents I think we're very understanding
of of me and I'm generally a quite a
well-behaved child I was not and I'll
leave it at that
okay well should we uh yes Stuart
Smalley been a part of your persona yeah
we get back to the Stuart Smalley I
don't know how many of you know about
this book with Stuart like in 91 or
something or 90 or something like that
so he's been that's so that's you have a
question or yeah okay straight um I was
like your call wasn't the 80s the decade
of Al Franken yeah yeah so what was the
90s 90s was a gel Franken decade he's my
son and we're about to enter the Al
Franken millennium
so well I think thank you very much I
wanna I forgot to say that I'm Carla
Cohen and one of the owners of politics
and prose and my partner Barbara Mead
and I both are very very grateful to you
for coming and there's something about
this book I have to say that although
it's very funny it's none of it seems
very implausible to me John is gonna
give you some directions of how we're
going to proceed thanks again for coming
and thank you very much I'll
coming
holding kids 17 and 14 make your
emphasis given solvent stripes I
yeah I actually think they're kind of
smart I think that he's looking out for
future chief justice's that they should
distinguish themselves mirror associate
justices who's Katie who's Christine
share the book thank you thank you
thanks very health including entitled
okay we'll see what's this the title
he's trying to sneak in a title it's not
a message
I know I did thank you sir Thank You
Mitch hi Sandy how are you good
I saw you when you did the National
Press Club work dinner for the president
everything you're really really funny we
watch it at work probably the way of
course that was fun take care of sandy
this is a whole family you gotta sign
only my son still enjoys Michael I'm
still enjoys watching on Comedy Central
the old sorry night lives with you oh
yeah well beginning residuals Thanks I
there now down the like I get things
like 13,000 stuff
thanks it depends on the year they're
made and with it with a Writers Guild
contract after contract was but I've
actually gotten like once and checks
your bankruptcy nine dollars and put it
out there you Blanche me my Blanche I
thank you thank you
loses to just just with system okay
you'll hear all the women get lucky yeah
just signature okay thanks a lot thanks
going very hungry banyan oh that was
well I love him we had people singing
Moses in our Christmas carols for a row
yes we we've adopted that as a
yeah you know I asked them if there are
any Jews and like global good like they
don't even like talking about thank you
you know if you're gonna be doing any of
the election coverage for Comedy Central
in two thousand probably but I don't
know it depends what's going on there
but I'd love to yeah do it somewhere
anyway you advance it it's one behind
that oh thank you
okay one can come around here you're my
only living hero really it's pretty sad
isn't that is very who died yeah they're
dead
Oh